en el vídeo acerca de la meiosis nos
quedamos en que teníamos dos gametos
teníamos un espermatozoide y un óvulo
permítanme dibujar al espermatozoide así
que teníamos el espermatozoide
y teníamos un óvulo por aquí
y ya sabemos qué ocurre después el
espermatozoide fecunda el óvulo y toda
una cascada de eventos empieza a ocurrir
las paredes del óvulo se vuelven
impermeables a los demás espermatozoides
de manera que solo un espermatozoide
pueda entrar pero ese no es el objetivo
de este vídeo el objetivo de este vídeo
es ver qué ocurre con este óvulo
fecundado que ocurre con él una vez que
se ha convertido en un cigoto y vimos en
los vídeos acerca de la meiosis que cada
uno de estos era a floyd es que tenían
la mitad del número normal de cromosomas
lloyd
lloyd en cuanto el espermatozoide
fertiliza este óvulo tenemos un cigoto
diploide voy a dibujar eso ahora vamos a
tener un cigoto diploide que va a tener
un número doble de cromosomas o que va a
tener el número completo de cromosomas
de acuerdo con lo que una célula normal
del cuerpo humano tendría
así que esto es diploide y es un cigoto
que es solo una forma elegante de decir
que es un óvulo fecundado y está listo
para convertirse en un organismo así que
inmediatamente después de que ocurre la
fecundación
esto es igual todo comienza a
experimentar una segmentación está
experimentando una mitosis ese sería el
mecanismo pero no aumenta mucho de
tamaño así que esta de aquí se
convertirá en dos sólo se va a dividir a
través de la mitosis en dos así y por
supuesto estos son diploides y luego
estos se van a dividir en cuatro y cada
uno de ellos tienen la misma información
genética que el primer cigoto y se sigue
dividiendo y esta masa de células le
podríamos llamar así se conoce como
modula
y esta palabra viene del latín que
significa mora porque se ve como una
mora
así que voy a resumir un poco todo esto
empezamos con un cigoto que es un óvulo
fecundado
y comienza a duplicarse por medio de la
mitosis y terminamos con un montón de
células a menudo el número de células va
a ser una potencia de 2 ya que estas
células por lo menos en las etapas
iniciales se están duplicando todas a la
vez y luego tenemos esta modula
modula
una vez que la modula tiene
aproximadamente 16 células y estamos
hablando de que esto sucede en 4 o 5
días empiezan a diferenciarse un poco
esto se convierte en una estructura de
tipo esférica lo voy a dibujar por aquí
permítanme hacer algunas células
externas esto sería una sección
transversal de la modula lamorú la va a
parecerse más a una esfera estas son las
células externas y aquí tenemos las
células internas
al conjunto de células externas se les
llama trozo blast
job
blast o
y las células internas y esto es el eje
central de este vídeo al conjunto de
células internas se les llama embrión
blast y lo que va a ocurrir a
continuación es que un líquido va a
comenzar a rellenar este espacio entre
el embrión blast y el trofeo blast o así
que van a empezar a tener un poco de
líquido
entonces llegará un momento en el que la
modula se verá así como la dibujaré
enseguida el trofeo blast o la membrana
externa va a ser una enorme esfera de
estas células y todo esto está
sucediendo mientras se siguen replicando
por medio de la mitosis ahora el trofeo
blast o se va a ver así
y el embrión las dos se va a ver así
este es el empleo blast
brillo
blast
a veces también se le llama masa celular
interna
más
celular
interna
y esto es lo que se va a convertir en el
organismo y solo para que conozcas un
par de nombres que se encuentran
involucrados aquí si estamos hablando de
un organismo de tipo mamífero y nosotros
somos mamíferos decimos que tenemos un
cigoto que se convierte en una modula y
las células de la médula comienzan a
diferenciarse en el trozo blast y el
embrión blast y aquí se forma este
espacio en el que se encuentra el fluido
y se le llama blast o cl
blast
y una vez que esto se forma a esto se le
llama blastocisto a todo esto se le
llama blast o sisto
y este es el caso en los seres humanos
humanos
ahora este puede ser un tema muy confuso
porque a veces en un montón de libros de
biología te vas a encontrar que dicen
que la modula pasa directamente a hacer
la plántula o la blastos fera déjame
escribir esas palabras por acá así que a
veces te puedes encontrar que los libros
dicen que se pasa del amor u la
ah
laplace tula
a veces llamada plaza esfera blas todo
esfera y quiero dejar muy claro que
estas son esencialmente las mismas
etapas en el desarrollo para cualquier
especie en varios libros te encontrarás
que van a empezar a hablar de ranas o
renacuajos o cosas por el estilo y esto
se aplica a ellos mientras que si
estamos hablando de mamíferos
especialmente los que están
estrechamente relacionados con nosotros
a esta fase se le llama fase de
blastocisto
y la verdadera diferencia es que cuando
la gente habla solo de la plántula o
blastos fera no necesariamente existe
esta diferenciación entre estas células
externas y estos embryo blastos o esta
masa celular interna pero dado que el
objetivo de este vídeo es hablar acerca
del ser humano vamos a centrarnos en el
blastocisto ahora bien todo lo que hemos
dicho en este vídeo era para llegar a
este punto porque lo que tenemos aquí
estas pequeñas células verdes que dibujé
aquí en el blastocisto esta masa celular
interna esto es lo que se va a convertir
en el organismo y puede que te estés
preguntando si ese es el organismo
entonces que son estas células moradas
de aquí este trozo blanco
eso se va a convertir en el caso de los
humanos en la placenta se va a convertir
en la placenta
y la placenta es el órgano dentro del
cual el embrión se desarrolla y es la
interfaz esencialmente en los seres
humanos y en los mamíferos entre el feto
en desarrollo y su madre se podría decir
que es la superficie de intercambio que
separa a estos dos sistemas y que
permite ser en las funciones necesarias
entre ellos pero ese no es el tema
central de este vídeo el objetivo de
este vídeo es el hecho de que estas
células que en este punto ya se han
diferenciado de las células de la
placenta pero todavía no han decidido en
qué se van a convertir
tal vez esta célula y sus descendientes
comienzan a volverse parte del sistema
nervioso
mientras que estas células de aquí
podrían convertirse en el tejido
muscular
y estas células podrían convertirse en
el hígado
estas células son llamadas células madre
embrionarias y probablemente esta es la
primera vez en este vídeo que estás
escuchando un término que podrías
reconocer y solo para presentarles un
nuevo término tenemos este cigoto y en
cuanto se comienza a dividir a cada una
de estas células se les llama blastómera
y posiblemente te estás preguntando por
qué siguen apareciendo palabras que
contienen el término blast en los vídeos
sobre embriología es porque viene del
griego para germen blastos que puede ser
definido como un tejido biológico que da
origen a un ser vivo no voy a entrar a
detalle en los orígenes de la palabra
pero de ahí viene y es por eso que
muchas de estas palabras tienen blast
así que estos son blast o meros
y cuando hablo de células madre
embrionarias me refiero a los blast o
menos individuales dentro de este
embrión blast o dentro de esta masa
celular interna así que cada uno de
estos es una célula madre embrionaria
esto es de aquí son
células madre embrionarias
células
y madre embrionarias
y justo quería llegar a esto y la razón
por la cual son interesantes y creo que
ya lo saben es que hay un gran debate en
torno a estas estas células tienen el
potencial de convertirse en cualquier
tipo de célula del cuerpo tienen esta
plasticidad esta es otra palabra que
puedes llegar a escuchar y la palabra
esencialmente se refiere a que algo es
como un plástico que puede convertirse
en otra cosa cuando decimos que algo
tiene plasticidad
estamos hablando acerca de su potencial
para convertirse en una gran cantidad de
cosas diferentes así que la teoría es y
ya se han hecho algunas pruebas que
parecen corroborar esto la teoría es que
si en algún momento tu cuerpo se ve
dañado de alguna forma déjame dibujar
una célula nerviosa
no voy a entrar en la mecánica de una
célula nerviosa pero vamos a decir que
tenemos algún daño en un cierto punto en
una célula nerviosa
y debido a este daño alguien está
paralizado o tiene algún tipo de
disfunción nerviosa o padece algún tipo
de esclerosis múltiple o algo así la
idea es que tenemos estas células aquí
que podrían convertirse en cualquier
tipo de célula y estamos apenas
entendiendo cómo es que sabe en qué
convertirse tiene que observar su
entorno y decir hey qué están haciendo
las células que están a mi alrededor y
tal vez eso es lo que ayuda a dictar en
que se va a convertir pero la idea es
que se puede tomar estas células que
podrían convertirse en cualquier tipo de
célula y se colocan en el lugar donde se
encuentra el daño se colocan capas de
estas células madre en el lugar dañado y
así se convierten en las células que se
necesitan para revertir el daño en este
caso se convertirían en células
nerviosas ellas se volverían células
nerviosas y repararían los daños y tal
vez curarían la parálisis de
individuo así que es un área enorme y
emocionante de investigación incluso se
podría en teoría hacer crecer nuevos
órganos si alguien necesita un
trasplante de riñón o un trasplante de
corazón tal vez en el futuro se podría
tomar una colonia de estas células madre
embrionarias tal vez podamos ponerla en
alguna criatura o algo así y podamos
convertirla en un corazón de repuesto o
en un riñón de repuesto así que hay
mucho entusiasmo acerca de lo que estas
células pueden hacer podrían curar
muchas enfermedades que antes eran
incurables o dar esperanza a muchos
pacientes que de lo contrario podrían
morir pero obviamente hay un debate aquí
y el debate gira en torno a la siguiente
cuestión si quisieras tratar de extraer
una de estas células vas a matar a este
embrión vas a matar a este embrión en
desarrollo y el embrión en desarrollo
tenía el potencial de convertirse en un
ser humano
potencial ya que tiene que estar en el
entorno adecuado y tiene que tener una
madre dispuesta pero tiene el potencial
de convertirse en un ser humano por lo
que para aquellos sobre todo las
personas que están a favor de la vida se
podría decir son de la opinión de que
todo lo que tiene el potencial de
convertirse en un ser humano debe de ser
respetado como ser vivo y no debe de
matarse así que las personas a favor de
la vida o pro-vida están en contra de
que se destruya este embrión y este
vídeo no tiene como objetivo tomar
partido por cualquiera de los lados en
este debate pero esto sí tiene el
potencial de convertirse en un ser
humano
así que obviamente hay un debate
importante pero ahora ya que viste este
vídeo ahora sabes lo que la gente quiere
decir cuando están hablando de las
células madre embrionarias y tu
siguiente pregunta podría ser bueno
porque no solo las llaman células madre
en lugar de células madre embrionarias y
eso es porque en nuestro cuerpo tenemos
las llamadas células madres somáticas
déjame escribir eso
células
y madre somáticas o células madre
adultas y todos las tenemos están en
nuestra médula ósea para ayudar a
producir glóbulos rojos y en otras
partes de nuestro cuerpo pero el
problema con las células madre somáticas
es que no poseen tanta plasticidad lo
que significa que no pueden formar
cualquier tipo de célula en el cuerpo
humano hay toda un área de investigación
en donde se está intentando aumentar la
plasticidad de estas células y si
pudieran tomar estas células madres
somáticas y aumentar su plasticidad tal
vez podrían eliminar la necesidad de
utilizar estas células madre
embrionarias aunque tal vez si lo logran
y lo hacen demasiado bien tal vez podría
ocurrir que éstas también tengan el
potencial de convertirse en seres
humanos por lo que se convertiría en un
tema controvertido pero ahora mismo está
una vez un área de debate porque por su
propia cuenta una célula madre somática
o célula madre adulta no se convertirá
en un ser humano mientras que una célula
madre embrionarias y se implanta en una
madre dispuesta entonces por supuesto se
convertirá en un ser humano y quisiera
hacer una nota al margen porque este
vídeo no pretende tomar partido en este
debate simplemente los hechos son los
hechos estas células tienen el potencial
de convertirse en un ser humano pero
también tienen el potencial de salvar
millones de vidas ambas declaraciones
son hechos y tú puedes decidir por tu
cuenta que el lado de este debate deseas
tomar pero hay una cosa de la que quiero
hablar que en el debate público no se
menciona tenemos esta noción de que para
obtener una línea de células madre
embrionarias y cuando digo una línea de
células madre me refiero a tomar un par
de células madre
o digamos que tomamos una célula madre y
la colocamos en una caja de petri y
luego permites que se duplique
así que ésta se convierte en dos células
madre y esas dos a su vez se convierten
en cuatro entonces alguien podría tomar
una de estas y colocarla en su propia
caja de petri y estas son la línea de
células madre
todas ellas procedían de una célula
madre embrionaria única o lo que
inicialmente era un blast homero eso es
lo que se llama una línea de células
madre así que el debate es que cuando se
inicia una línea celular embrionarias se
está destruyendo a un embrión pero
también quisiera mencionar que existen
otros procedimientos que matan embriones
uno de ellos es la fertilización in
vitro
y tal vez haga el siguiente vídeo acerca
de la fertilización in vitro y de manera
general este es un procedimiento en el
que se toman una serie de óvulos de una
mujer por lo general se lleva a cabo
cuando una pareja está teniendo
problemas para concebir un hijo se
llevan un montón de óvulos de la mujer
digamos que toman tal vez de 10 a 30
óvulos de la mujer se realiza una
cirugía para sacarlos de los ovarios de
la mujer y luego los fertilizan con
semen ya sea que éste provenga del padre
o de un donante por lo que todos estos
se convierten en cigotos una vez que se
han fertilizado con el esperma así que
todos estos se convierten en cigotos y
luego dejan que se desarrollen y por lo
general los dejan desarrollarse hasta la
fase de blastocisto así que ellos se
convierten en blastocistos
tienen un vasto cl en el centro que es
esta área con líquido
tienen la masa celular interna y lo que
hacen es que observan a las células que
consideren que son las más saludables y
toman un par de estas células y las
implantan en la madre todo esto ocurre
en una caja de petri así que tal vez
estas cuatro se ven bien así que van a
tomar estas cuatro y las van a implantar
en la madre y si todo va bien tal vez
una de éstas se convertirá en un bebé
así que tal vez ésta se desarrollará y
tal vez las otras no pero muchas veces
se implantan
muchas de estas células sólo para
aumentar la probabilidad de que se
obtenga al menos un hijo
pero de vez en cuando se implantan siete
u ocho y ocurre que se desarrollan las
ocho y terminas con ocho bebés y es por
eso que la fertilización in vitro a
menudo resulta en este tipo de embarazos
múltiples pero qué es lo que hacen con
todos estos otros embriones que son o
que pueden ser perfectamente viables
pueden o no pueden ser perfectamente
viables pero tienes estos embriones que
tienen el potencial de convertirse en
seres humanos al igual que este de aquí
todos ellos llegan al potencial de
convertirse en un ser humano pero la
mayoría de las clínicas de fertilidad
más o menos la mitad de ellas ya sea que
tiren a estas células o que las
destruyan o que las dejen morir muchas
de ellas son congeladas pero solo el
proceso de congelación las mata así que
en el proceso de fertilización in vitro
por todo aquel embrión que tiene el
potencial de convertirse en un ser
humano en realidad se están destruyendo
decenas de embriones viables así que me
parece que si una persona está en contra
y en general no quiero tomar partido en
esto pero si estás en contra de la
investigación que involucra células
madre embrionarias
células
embrionarias
debido a la destrucción de embriones en
el mismo podríamos decir terreno
filosófico también deberías de estar en
contra de la fertilización in vitro
fertilización
vitro
ya que ambas implican la destrucción de
cigotos no voy a hablar más sobre esto
porque realmente no quiero tomar partido
pero quiero demostrar que hay una
especie de equivalencia aquí que se
pierde completamente en este debate de
si las células madre embrionarias deben
ser utilizadas o no debido a que
implican la destrucción de embriones ya
que en otros procedimientos como la
fertilización in vitro se está
destruyendo embriones también hay
cientos de miles de embriones que se
destruyen o son congelados y son
destruidos en ese proceso también al
pasar por este proceso de fertilización
in vitro ahora ya tienen las
herramientas para formar tu opinión en
el debate en torno a las células madre y
puedes ver que todo viene de lo que
aprendimos acerca de la meiosis se
producen estos gametos el gameto
masculino fertiliza un gameto femenino
se crea el cigoto y se inicia la
división hasta llegar a la formación del
amor o la se continúa dividiendo y se
diferencia en el blastocisto
y aquí es donde las células madres se
encuentran así que ahora ya sabes
suficiente ciencia para participar en
algún debate muy acalorado al respecto